you may not want to admit it but
covid-19 is still around in fact a fast
spreading new variant is circulating
across Canada and across the globe so
how concerned should we be for The Fall
season well it's been a while but let's
bring in infectious diseases physician
Dr Isaac bogosh to shed some light on
the latest information good morning Dr
bogosh very good to see you after a
while
great to see you as well Candace so what
exact evidence is there that covid is on
the rise and why would it be at this
point
right it's important to remember that
covet obviously has never gone away uh
we're in a much better place now than we
were you know two and three years ago I
think that's very very obvious but of
course it's still here it's still
circulating and for the foreseeable
future it's going to Wax and Wane and
Wax and Wane over time if we look at
Canada across you know the entire
country we look at different mechanisms
to look at covid for example Wastewater
you can start to see some areas with an
uptick in that signal and of course
South of the Border they have seen a
rise in Wastewater surveillance they've
seen a rise in detected cases and and
sadly that that's corresponding to a
rise in in hospitalizations and in
people succumbing to the illness having
said that I think you know obviously we
don't want anyone to get covet uh but
you know it's it it's it's we're gonna
see that in Canada it's predictable
we're going to see a rise in cases in
the late summer and early fall and we
know what to do we've been here before
multiple times we have the tools to
protect ourselves and to protect those
around us yeah but here we are with yet
another new sub-variant of Omicron uh
what do we know so far about the eg.5 or
eg.5 and any concerns surrounding it
in all fairness I mean this is a virus
that continues to mutate we've been it's
still Omicron it's still under that
Omicron umbrella and you know we've been
through this multiple times over the
last year and a half where a new sub
lineage of Omicron has emerged we had
ba2 then ba4 then ba5 then xdb now eg5
and again it's I think what it's likely
keyword likely that we can expect
similar features to what we saw over the
last year and a half so if people want
to know what's this going to look like
it's probably going to resemble
something that we saw over the last year
and a half nothing like what we saw 2020
2021 and very very early 2022. alrighty
so the Canadian Medical Association
Journal found that 75 percent of
Canadians actually have immunity to
covid-19 do we know how long immunity
typically lasts
yeah it's a great Point thanks for
bringing that up I think when we're
talking about immunity we're talking
about people have either seen the virus
and responded to the virus or seen the
vaccine and responded to the vaccine or
a combination of those two and really
what that means is if you're exposed to
the virus again
the the high likelihood is that you're
just not going to have the same severe
outcome so basically we're talking about
reducing the risk of more severe
outcomes of covid-19 not blocking
infection with covet 19. people have had
covid-19 more than once we know that
people have been vaccinated and still
got cover 19. we know that and really
we're talking about at an individual
level reducing the risk of more severe
infection and then at a population level
we're talking about really reducing the
risk of more severe infections across a
larger population which as you can see
takes a lot of the burden off of a
Health Care system and and is not nearly
as disruptive remember earlier on in the
pandemic our Health Care system was
completely overwhelmed with covid-19 our
health care System currently of course
still has problems but it is not
overwhelmed with covid-19 uh even though
there still sadly are people coming into
hospital with covid-19 we're not
overwhelmed with this and I want to try
and fit this one in before we let you go
because uh you know back to school kids
are going to be heading back to the
classroom South of the Border we're
hearing rumors about a possible
triedemic that would be covid-19 the flu
and RSV How likely do you think that is
to happen here during the new school
year
well I mean I think we can remember last
year as well we had a lot of covid a lot
of influenza and a lot of RSV we know
those viruses are going to continue to
circulate so we will see flu come in the
fall we will see RSV come in the fall I
we don't have an RSV vaccine for kids at
this point in time but flu vaccines are
certainly around the corner and I I
think it's a very good idea for people
to get vaccinated to the flu it's not
perfect but of course it's the best we
have reduces the risk of severe illness
and reduces the chances of getting a
pretty nasty infection
and you know as you mentioned here we go
again so uh you know we have all of the
tools and in the tool kit to be able to
get us through this latest this latest
new sub-variant but thank you so much
for your time as always and for your
Insight that is Dr Isaac bogosh
infectious diseases specialist have a
great day